SIDE BEING CHRIS SUNUNU LOOKING
FOR WAYS TO NEEDLE DONALD TRUMP.
>>> WE BEGIN WITH THE BORDER
WHITE HOUSE.
IT'S ABOUT TO GO FROM BAD TO
WORSE.
A TRUMP ADMINISTRATION TURNED
THE BACK POLICY TITLE 42 COULD
EXPIRE NEXT WEEK.
IF IT DOES AN ALREADY STEADY
STREAM ACROSS THE U.S./MEXICO
BORDER IS PREDICTED TO DOUBLE IN
SIZE PERHAPS EVEN MORE THAN
THAT.
THAT ONE JARRING HEADLINE IS IN
A DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY MEMO.
LOCAL OFFICIALS WHO SEE THIS
EVERY DAY AGREE.
MORE MIGRANTS ARE JUST WAITING
FOR WORD TITLE 42 IS NO MORE.
AND THOSE OFFICIALS WARN,
ALREADY STRESSED SHELTERS AND
SERVICES ARE SOON TO BE
OVERWHELMED.
CNN ED LAVENDERA IS AT THE
BORDER.
ED, WHAT ARE YOU SEEING?
>> Reporter: WELL, JOHN, AS YOU
MENTIONED WE ARE ON THE JUAREZ
SIDE OF THE MEXICO/TEXAS BORDER
JUST ON THE SEAR SIDE, EL PASO.
THIS IS THE RIO GRANDE.
YOU CAN SEE THE ROCKY AREA.
A SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE JUST
SECONDS AGO WALKING ACROSS.
WANTED TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF
WHAT THIS RECENT SURGE WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT SO MUCH IN
THE EL PASO AREA LOOKS LIKE FROM
THE SIDE HERE IN MEXICO AND THIS
IS THE AREA WHERE MANY PEOPLE
ESSENTIALLY FREELY WALKING
ACROSS THE RIVER WHICH IS ONLY
25 TO 30 FEET.
JUST IN FRONT OF THE BORDER WALL
AND THE BARBED WIRE WALL AND
THIS LINE GOES ON FOR HUNDREDS
OF YARDS.
THERE HAVE BEEN THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN CROSSING
IN THE LAST WEEK OR SO AND THE
LATEST NUMBERS WE HAVE ARE
SAYING ABOUT ON AVERAGE ABOUT
2500 MIGRANTS HAVE BEEN CROSSING
HERE A DAY, WHICH REALLY IS
STUNNING ALL ORDER DERLY IT IS
WAITING THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT.
ESSENTIALLY WALKING ACROSS THE
BORDER AND WAITING TO TURN
THEMSELVES IN TO BORDER PATROL
AGENTS.
IN A LONG LINE HERE WAITING
FOR -- IF YOU LOOK ACROSS NOW
BORDER PATROL AGENTS ARE
SIGNALING JUST A HANDFUL OF
PEOPLE TO COME THROUGH PAST THE
WALL THERE EVERY FEW MINUTES OR
SO AND THEN THEY ARE ESCORTED
SEVERAL HUNDRED YARDS ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THAT WALL TO A
BORDER PATROL PROCESSING
FACILITY.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THOSE
FACILITIES ARE ALREADY
OVERCAPACITY AS YOU MENTIONED IN
THE LEAD IN THERE THAT THE
SHELTERS AND THE HUMANITARIAN
EFFORTS ON THE OTHER SIDE IN EL
PASO WERE ALREADY OVERWHELMED.
BUT WHAT IS LOOMING OVER ALL
THIS, JOHN, THE PROSPECT OF
TITLE 42 BEING SUSPENDED NEXT
WEEK.
THIS IS A SURGE DIFFERENT FROM
ALL OF THAT BUT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS PREPARING FOR
AS MANY AS 9,000 TO 14,000
PEOPLE CROSSING THE BORDER DAILY
AND ONCE TITLE 42 IS LIFTED, IF
YOU FOLLOW ME OVER HERE ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE STREET,
THERE'S A CAR WASH AND WHERE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SLEEPING AND
THOSE ARE MOSTLY -- I WAS
TALKING TO THEM.
MOSTLY VENEZUELAN MIGRANTS.
ONE GENTLEMAN SAID HE'S BEEN
DEPORTED FOUR TIMES IN THE LAST
TWO MONTHS BECAUSE OF TITLE 42
AND HE IS NOW WAITING UNTIL NEXT
WEEK TO SEE IF HE CAN GET
THROUGH HERE.
SO THIS IS AN AREA WHERE THERE
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE SLEEPING IN
SHELTERS, A MIX OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE JUST SAYING, WE'VE COME A
LONG WAY.
WE'LL CROSS NOW.
OTHER PEOPLE TRYING TO TAKE A
WAIT AND SEE APPROACH.
BUT ALL OF THIS IS FACTORING IN
TO WHAT WE'LL SEE NEXT WEEK ONCE
THE POSSIBILITY OF TITLE 42
BEING LIFTED, JOHN.
>> ED, THANKS TO YOU AND YOUR
TEAM.
CRITICAL REPORTING, JUST SOUTH
OF THE U.S./MEXICO BORDER ON THE
MEXICO SIDE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THOSE PICTURES ARE CERTAINLY
MORE THAN DRAMATIC.
>>> JOINING ME IS DANA BASH,
NIA-MALIKA HENDERSON AND YOU
LOOK AT THE PICTURES AND ED
MAKES THE KEY POINT, DAILY
IMMIGRATION AND THEN THERE ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE WELL AWARE
TITLE 42 IS ABOUT TO DISAPPEAR,
AT LEAST BELIEVED TO DISAPPEAR
NEXT WEEK WAITING SLEEPING IN A
CAR WASH, PARKING LOTS.
THIS IS WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY MEMO SAYS
ABOUT THIS.
OUR PRISCILLA ALVAREZ SAYS, THE
END OF THE POLICY WILL INCREASE
MIGRANT FLOWS IMMEDIATELY AND
MIGRANTS IN ENCAMPMENTS ALONG
THE NORTHERN BORDER MAY ATTEMPT
TO CROSS.
AND THAT MEMO GOES ON TO SAY
THEY THINK THIS COULD POSSIBLY
DOUBLE.
DOES THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAVE A PLAN FOR THIS?
PLEASE CORRECT ME IF YOU THINK
I'M WRONG BUT THEY SEEM AGAIN TO
BE REACTIONARY, NOT PROACTIVE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN, THERE'S BEEN SOME
REPORTING IN AXIOS AND OTHER
PLACES THEY'RE HAVING
DISCUSSIONS.
I THINK KARINE JEAN-PIERRE SAID
THERE HAVE BEEN NO DECISIONS
MADE JUST YET, BUT IT'S NOT JUST
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, I
THINK DEMOCRATS ARE ALSO VERY
REACTIONARY AND NOT TALKING
ABOUT THIS.
I INTERVIEWED REPRESENTATIVE
CLYBURN THIS MORNING FOR
WASHINGTON POST LIVE AND ASKED
IF THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
NEEDS TO DO MORE.
WHAT TO DO ABOUT TITLE 42 AND
SAID HE DOESN'T HAVE AN OPINION
ABOUT IT.
THAT HE JUST MET WITH SOMEONE
WHO WAS ON THE BORDER, AND
THOUGHT THAT THE BORDER ACTUALLY
LOOKED PRETTY GOOD AND SO THAT
IS THE SAME LINE OF DEMOCRATS,
THAT, YOU KNOW, KIND OF SAYING
ON ONE HAND IT'S NOT THAT BIG OF
A DEAL.
THINGS SEEM FINE AND IGNORING
THE ENTIRE SITUATION AND THESE
POLARIZED TIMES, REPUBLICANS
HAVE THE EXACT OPPOSITE
APPROACH.
>> YOU'RE LOOKING AT PICTURES
THAT ED AND HIS CREW ARE FEEDING
IN.
IT DOES NOT LOOK GOOD WHATEVER
YOUR VIEWS.
IF YOU WANT MORE PEOPLE TO COME
INTO THE UNITED STATES, IF YOU
WANT MORE LEGAL IMMIGRATION INTO
THE UNITED STATES, PICTURES LIKE
THIS DO NOT HELP YOUR CAUSE.
>> RIGHT.
IT'S, OF COURSE, NOT ORDERLY AT
ALL.
THERE'S A CRUSH OF HUMANITY
THERE.
PEOPLE FLEEING THESE VERY
UNSTABLE COUNTRIES LIKE
NICARAGUA, VENEZUELA, AND CUBA
AS WELL.
FOR AWHILE IT SEEMED LIKE KAMALA
HARRIS, THIS WAS HER PORTFOLIO,
RIGHT.
TO GET TO THE ROOT CAUSES IN
SOME OF THESE COUNTRIES AND
DESTABILIZED GOVERNMENTS BUT
THAT'S KIND OF IMPOSSIBLE
BECAUSE A LOT HAVE DICTATORS WHO
ARE CRACKING DOWN ON CIVIL
SOCIETY, THEY'RE, YOU KNOW, DRUG
WARLORDS AND THAT IS WHAT
THEY'RE FLEEING AND HARD TO
REALLY STEM THAT IN THOSE ROOT
COUNTRIES.
SO, LISTEN, BUT I THINK WE'VE
BEEN HERE BEFORE AND IT DOES
SEEM LIKE EVERY SINGLE TIME THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SEEMS A BIT
SLOW ON THEIR HEELS TO ACTUALLY
REACT.
>> SO WE'RE JUST A LITTLE OVER
TWO WEEKS AWAY FROM REPUBLICANS
CONTROLLING THE HOUSE WHICH IS
GOING TO CHANGE THE TONE AND
TENOR OF THIS CONVERSATION.
THIS IS TONY GONZALEZ,
REPUBLICAN MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
ON TELEVISION TODAY.
LISTEN TO HIM.
HE SAYS, YES, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION NEEDS TO DO
SOMETHING BUT HE'S ALREADY
MAKING THE CASE THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO SO CONGRESS WOMEN.
>> I FEAR THE WORST IS YET TO
COME AND WE'RE JUST SEEING THE
TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
WHILE THE ADMINISTRATION HAS A
ROLE TO PLAY IN THIS AND SHOULD
CERTAINLY BE PART OF THIS,
CONGRESS HAS A ROLE TO PLAY AND
CONGRESS NEEDS TO LEAD.
IT IS DIFFICULT FOR ME TO TALK
ABOUT IMMIGRATION REFORM WHEN I
HAVE 50,000 MIGRANTS WAITING ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE BORDER.
>> HE SAYS CONGRESS NEEDS TO
LEAD.
THE ISSUE AND SADLY FOR 20 PLUS
YEAR, THE HOUSE REPUBLICANS HAVE
THEIR IDEAS.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE THEIR IDEAS
AND REFUSE TO GET IN A ROOM AND
FIGURE IS THERE 40%, 50% WE CAN
AGREE ON.
LET'S DO THIS AND COME BACK NEXT
MONTH AND TALK ABOUT THE REST OF
IT.
>> WHEN THEY DO GET IN A ROOM
SEVERAL YEARS AGO AT THIS POINT,
BOTH SIDE, MOSTLY THE REPUBLICAN
SIDE UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DEMAGOGUED TO THE
POINT WHERE WHATEVER THEY WERE
TRYING TO COME UP WITH
COMPLETELY FELL APART.
YES, THERE IS A COMPLETE BACKUP
OF HUMANITY AT THE BORDER RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE OF TITLE 4 OUT OF A
BECAUSE OF COVID AND THAT STILL
EXISTS, BUT THIS IS A CRISIS
THAT HAS BUILT UP FOR MORE THAN
20 YEARS AND IT IS BECAUSE
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS BOTH
HAVE BEEN IN CHARGE OVER THE
PAST COUPLE OF DECADES,
REPUBLICANS IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
DEMOCRATS IN THE WHITE HOUSE
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO GET THEIR
ACT TOGETHER AND IT IS BECAUSE
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST SADLY
ONE OF THE MOST HIJACKED ISSUES
BY BOTH SIDES TO BE DEMAGOGUED
THAT THEY SAY -- THEY DON'T SAY
THIS BUT THE REALITY IS THEY
WOULD MUCH RATHER HAVE AN ISSUE
THAN A SOLUTION.
>> THERE WAS A PROPOSAL THAT IS
NOW SAID TO BE OFF THE RAILS.
NOT DONE WITH THE LAME DUCK YEAR
END CONGRESSIONAL SESSION YET
BUT SENATOR SINEMA FROM ARIZONA,
A BORDER STATE THAT LEFT THE
DEMOCRATS TO BECOME AN
INDEPENDENT, THOM TILLIS WERE
WORKING ON A PLAN TO DEAL WITH
THE MODEST PIECES, MORE BORDER
SECURITY FUNDING WHICH
REPUBLICANS SAY THEY WANT.
GIVE STATUS TO THE SO-CALLED
DREAMERS, YOUNG PEOPLE BROUGHT
ACROSS THE BORDER WHETHER THEY
WERE TOO YOUNG THEMSELF TO MAKE
THE DECISION.
EVEN THAT, SOMETHING THAT WOULD
GET MAJORITY SUPPORT LIKE THAT
THEY WON'T BRING TO THE FLOOR
BECAUSE OF WHAT, JUST COMPETING
POLITICAL INTERESTS?
>> THERE'S NOT THE VOTES.
SINEMA AND TILLIS HAVE AN
AGREEMENT AMONGST THEMSELVES BUT
YOU NEED 60 VOTES IN THE SENATE.
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE HOUSE
DEMOCRATS ARE THAT INTERESTED.
THIS BILL IS A BIG INVESTMENT IN
BORDER SECURITY.
BUT THERE'S TWO THINGS HERE.
ARE DEMOCRATS GOING TO AGREE
WITH IT AND ALSO MOST
REPUBLICANS NOW ARE SAYING THEY
WILL DO NOTHING ON IMMIGRATION
INCLUDING DACA UNTIL THE BORDER
IS SECURE.
NOT SIMULTANEOUSLY BUT UNTIL AND
THERE'S NO ROOM FOR A COMPROMISE
OR NEGOTIATION AT TH